passons maintenant notre panel municipal
on retrouve anie samson et luc ferrandez
bonsoir à vous deux montants semble que
l'on sauvé ya pas longtemps
ça fait des grosses journées parlez-nous
là on est 24 heures après cette
impression de vent de changement de
l'image qui sont plus jeunes beaucoup de
femmes ont dit qu'un changement de
génération hier tout le monde était un
peu dans l'enthousiasmé 24 heures plus
tard est-ce que dans tout ça c'est
toujours le votre lecture et dit moi je
trouve ça très intéressant parce qu'on
le disait un moment donné va avoir un
choc de générations et on lui maintenant
donc partout au québec pour justement
rien mais c'est partout au québec on a
des jeunes on est des femmes cinq plus
grandes villes tu le dis cinq plus
grandes villes au québec c'est des
femmes qu'ils ont des femmes qui sont
jeunes on voit que les priorités vont
changer aussi ça dynamise un peu le seul
bémol que je mets c'est la participation
le taux de participation on aura
peut-être le temps d'en parler louis
c'est décevant
mais écoutez moi je pense qu'il devrait
agir rapidement ils ont à peu près la
même vision du monde ils sont ils
peuvent s'unir pour demander à québec
tout de suite une reconnaissance par
exemple de la crise du logement celui
québec quand je me fais cette
reconnaissance là il doit faire pression
immédiatement aussi pour obtenir des
changements à la régie du logement sur
les rénovations c'est un exemple mais y
en a plein d'autres mais éviterait à
faire tout de suite d'une réunion de
travail et a tout de suite montré leur
poids et leur nom et leur rétention bon
quand on dit aussi vent de changement on
dit qu'on n'a jamais autant parlé de
transition environnementale par exemple
de changement climatique c'est facile
les mots c'est bon les mots dans une
campagne électorale luc on sait à quel
point c'est important pour vous tous
sommet dans les faits ça veut dire des
gros changement des goûts changement qui
souvent qu'ils soient hommes ont
polarisé une population polarisé une
avez vous l'impression que ces jeunes là
un vrai plus au dessus de leurs aînés
j'ai hâte de le voir justement je trouve
que c'est vraiment la question du jour
et des prochains mois par exemple si on
veut réduire la place de la voiture est
ce qu'on veut imposer une taxe
kilométrique est ce qu'on devrait avoir
on favorise les gens qui prennent le
métro vers montréal et pas ceux qui
prennent leur voiture sur les ponts
c'est une possibilité je dise pas que
c'est dans les intentions des nouveaux
élus est nouvelle et du jeudi que c'est
une possibilité et c'est ça moi
effectivement je vais voir ce canton du
vent de changement est ce que ça veut
juste dire plus de cheveux plus de
sourires ou ça veut dire plus
d'intention qu'on concrètes j'ai hâte de
le voir oui parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
déjà vu des jeunes faire des vieilles
politiques oui tout à fait mais mais là
dedans il va y avoir eu des changements
mais il faut se rappeler aussi quel est
le rôle de base de la ville se devrait
des services dans les quartiers dans
pour les femmes et pour les gens qui
sont là on a beau parler de transition
écologique mais va quand même pouvoir
déneiger les rues ramasser les poubelles
nettoyer puis ramasser une ferme au nid
poule il ya quand même le travail de
base qui doit être fait le reste est
tout aussi important parce qu'on
s'enligne pour changer un peu nos façons
de faire il va falloir que le budget
viennent aussi avec en politique la
première chose c'est qu'en priori l'on
doit renoncer est là actuellement c'est
c'est dans les prochaines semaines est
nouveau et luc devront regarder leur
budget puisse dire maintenant qu'est ce
qu'on est capable faire avec l'argent
vous l'impression qui en a qui vont être
déçus certains qui sont lancés dans 50
sur les lieux qui vont faire toute une
découverte le 1er leur budget doit être
déposée maintenant c'est une
particularité du système municipal les
élections ont lieu en novembre le budget
doit être déposé en décembre un
apprentissage très très très rapide des
enjeux moi j'ai été témoin de d'élus qui
pensait avoir beaucoup d'argent qui ont
réalisé que c'était pas du tout le col
les projets qt faut laisser ça pour la
deuxième année par contre il faut
engager tout de suite tout de suite tout
de suite des actions parce que ce qu'on
ne commence pas dans la première année
on ne le finira pas avant la troisième
alors c'est tout de suite qu'il faut
agir bon votre lecture de ce qui s'est
passé à montréal hier soir cette
victoire éclatante de madame plantes
alors si on regarde ce maintenant avec
le lendemain qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
new york il qu'est ce que vous retenez
touche au bout ben moi ce que je retiens
c'est que la campagne d'ensemble
montréal c'est monsieur coderre qui le
perdu si on regarde dans les
arrondissements où il ya encore quand
même six arrondissements ou ensemble
mariage en gagner la mairie les votes
qui allaient qui devrait aller à
monsieur coderre aller à madame plantes
et localement le vote allait ensemble
mangeable donc il ya quand même eu je
pense qu'on l'a vu la campagne s'est
tenue au delà ces serments sur les
promesses parce que elles étaient
semblables d'un parti à l'autre mais
elle s'est tenue beaucoup sur les
personnalités et on ne revue la même on
a vécu la main le même type de campagne
qu'en 2010 est en fait ouais
les miser sur le nouveau corner de
personnes qui parlent du nouveau code r
aujourd'hui
effectivement malheureusement c'était
c'était du vent et moi je me désole du
champ de ruines qui laisse derrière lui
des élus de grande qualité qui étaient
ensemble montréal et qui n'ont pas passé
la rampe lé jeu hadrien parizeau
lionel perez catherine bois karine
boivin roi des personnes qui ont une
connaissance de la ville un engagement
une motivation est qui et qui
disparaissent je trouve ça très
difficile pour ensemble montréal et
j'essaie de voir d'où va venir
l'opposition alors il reste des
personnes intéressantes de christine
black est figé à nous et c mais il ya
aussi des vieux routiers qui sont
l'homme qui vont prendre l'essentiel de
la place de jim bay st michel
bissonnette c'est un champ de ruines
vraiment l'opposition arrivera pas jouer
correctement son rôle ça va de quoi
l'avenir de monsieur coderre à votre
avis parce que la personne de séance
mais ils restent où ils restent pas
parce que là il ya plus chef de
l'opposition monsieur perez a été aperçu
dans côte des neiges notre dame de grâce
annie est ce que vous savez des choses
qu'on sait pas sur le sucre de sel est
une non mais je pense pas sincèrement
qu'ils vont revenir parce qu'il leur ait
dit hier probablement parce que ce que
je vois là maintenant c'est un
opportunité pour ensemble montréal de
pouvoir rené deux autres même avec les
nouveaux élus parce que quand même des
nouveaux élus qui ont été élu comme
conseiller dans divers arrondissements
et je pense qu'ensemble ils pourront se
trouver un leader ou
deux leaders là pour pouvoir continuer
parce que des gens quand même qu'ils ont
encore l'expérience ils pourront ils
pourront refaire revivre ce parti là
parce que quand même vont avoir des
budgets de fonctionnement ils sont quand
même l'opposition officielle et leur
présente des citoyens mais il va falloir
qu'ils le font entre eux et que monsieur
coderre mais puisqu'elle plus l'ombre de
monsieur coderre sur le parti pour leur
laisser les bretons à s'organiser parce
que pendant les quatre dernières années
ils ont fait un excellent travail
d'évolution et ils l'ont fait ensemble
où tout le monde a pu participer et
c'est ce que je souhaite actuellement
que l'ensemble real actuel avec les élus
puissent continuer à faire ce travail là
parce que c'est eux qui ont les plus
grandes expériences sur le milieu
municipal luc sur l'avenir politique de
monsieur coderre mais premièrement je
pense que il ya une question qui se pose
est ce qui reste une dette ensemble
montréal deux bus scolaire avait fait
une des de créer une dette de 300 mille
dollars à la première élection à la
dernière élection est ce qu'aujourd'hui
un d'être ensemble montréal si c'est un
gentleman il voudra peut-être pas partir
tout de suite sans régler cette dette là
ça c'est une première possibilité je
pense aussi comme annie que c'est le
temps d'avoir du sang neuf il ya
christine black qui est une personne qui
est une des leaders dans l'ensemble
montréal qui a été élu et j'ai ce serait
formidable je trouve franchement de
montréal gabriel recteur qui a pas été
élu il y en a d'autres qui ont été élus
mais qui sont aussi à l'arrière-scène
que c'est une blague pour être une bonne
bonne bonne possibilité là pour casser
le moral sur à lens et j'ai une femme
maman ça ira un peu dans le monde
changements aussi oui ces nouveaux
candidats dont on parle est faite de ces
nouveaux élus et au jury mais aussi une
poigne de fer que ces blacks peuvent pas
facile à tasser là ça pourrait être une
très bonne leaders de l'opposition dont
qu'est ce que vous retenez davanture de
balram en laisse maintenant alors une
fois parvenu à faire élire deux
conseillers mais est ce qu'ils vont
rester quelque chose de ce mouvement là
c'est pour ça dans les intentions de
vote c'est pas beaucoup il ya fait quand
même un petit bout de chemin mais bon il
pourra et pourra continuer mais on va
pas de financement pour faire vivre ou
survivre son parti a pas atteint 115%
donc c'est un mouvement qui commence
est-ce qu'ils vont rester encore
peut-être c'est des gens qui se sont
permis de rêver aussi de faire la
différence j'espère qu'ils vont garder
encore le sentiment avait cueilli en
quatre ans pour le faire on les verra
sur le terrain peut-être sur les
terrains des conseils d'arrondissement
on pourra les voir le mais en dehors de
ça c'est à peu près la seule classe où
ils vont pouvoir parler parce qu'ils ont
trop de sièges oui pour être représenté
par un nouveau lieu qu'est ce que c'est
une clientèle qu'un des deux parties de
celui de mu anciennement je suis comment
dire le de monsieur coderre c'est
pourquoi pour aller chercher oui
vraiment il y avait là aussi à des
candidats formidables qui n'ont pas été
élus il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
potentiel j'espère qu'ils vont
transformer cette défaite là pas en
indignation mais un remise en question
et en se disant banques et comment on
fait pour s'insérer maintenant dans le
discours politique dans l'action
politique il ya des gens là dedans qui
peuvent le faire mais j'entendais encore
valoir à mort le 1/3 frôlé l'indignation
puis de dire au moins on a essayé n'ont
pas essayé d'amener 40 personnes à
l'abattoir dans tes dents tu es candidat
et ça c'est dramatique avec le mauvais
discours avec le mauvais positionnement
avec les mauvaises idées j'espère que de
ces personnes là vont pouvoir être
échappé il y en a là dans son excellent
est excellente pour la suite des choses
pour montréal on en parlait un peu plus
tôt son rapport de force avec les
paliers de gouvernement madame plan
d'aller bien en ciel réélu majoritaire
ça va changer quoi l'année mais alors
quand même eu un bon pourcentage de
votes donc lorsqu'elle va s'asseoir avec
québec avec ses autres mairesse aussi
les cinq grandes villes qui sont élus
par des méres mais le groupe des dix
c'est quand même important le ceci
arrive vraiment en disant je suis pas
une erreur c'est pas une erreur
d'élections j'ai vraiment été gagé gagné
deuxième mandat assez fort donc
maintenant elle va pouvoir s'asseoir
paix directes et on est la moitié du
québec montréal donc on a quand même un
point à celle aux eaux là dedans il ya
une élection provinciale l'année
prochaine
dans québec pas intéresse mais tu adores
morial surtout qu'ils ont juste deux
sièges actuellement la caq à montréal
donc s'ils veulent percer ils y auront
le choix de s'allier avec madame plantes
mais je félicite pour son élection le
taux de participation était quand même
coûté tout le monde se pose des
questions l'absence de mandat mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est quoi
c'est les gens qui pensaient peut-être
voter pour monsieur coderre qui sont pas
sortis du tout est ce que personne
s'intéresse à la politique municipale où
vous le quai lecture vous faites de ça
et que ce qui est en possession oui ça
fait partie ce que vous dites des gens
qui voulaient voter ni pour monsieur
coderre nimr madame plantes peut-être
qui avait été tenté par monsieur kader a
interdit en minutes sont pas sortis ça
pour expliquer son vote parce qu'on ne
fait pas un pouvoir en effet pas un
gouvernement en place sous une
administration en place avec 32 %
d'électeurs le ça prend plus de 50 % des
lecteurs donc ça se peut que ce soit des
pertes d quand des électeurs potentiels
dans son montréal qui ne soit pas sorti
mais l'autre chose aussi on parlait des
enjeux d'habitation de congestion de
l'environnement ce sont des enjeux
tellement il m'annonçait déjà que quelle
que soit la personne est dû de toute
manière questions vraiment les outils
pour faire le travail et ce qu'ils ont
c'est quoi votre réponse non ils les ont
pas ils ont pas il faut les forget il
faut les ranger dans des négociations
avec québec il faut décharger dans une
détermination est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des crises dans les prochaines années
qui vont faire ils vont être obligés
d'aller dans ce sens là moi je pense que
oui c'est ma lecture du monde et puis
d'ici quatre ans peut-être qu'ils vont
être être aguerri et puis qui vont
savoir approfondi leur volonté
d'appliquer des vraies mesures annie
merci encore pour ce panel aujourd'hui
merci au revoir